you know what I've always hated ghosts
whether they were those little freaks
and pac-man who gave me crazy anxiety
evil spirits that do really inconvenient
things like move your keys or tilt your
picture frames or this guy boom you
don't get to call me that until you
commit no I hate them even more because
I got ghosted for the first time and Wow
it really hurt and was scary so I really
like getting to know you we just like to
hang out on Thursday what does that mean
you're a ghost you're not invisible Nick
it's fine if you don't want to hang out
with me but just respond just answer me
just tell me but what was even worse was
when I told my friends about it I just
didn't see this coming like at all
Wow did you say that he consistently
flaked out initially when you guys were
trying to connect yeah but that was
coffee and we didn't really know each
other that and didn't you say that he'd
never follow through on anything he said
he was gonna do but he was busy and he
apologized for that and didn't you say
that he said that he didn't think
marriage would work out except for with
penguins okay but that's different okay
you don't give someone a pebble unless
you're serious but of course you can't
really blame those of us who act like
total idiots when we like someone
because fun fact just found this out
when people begin falling in love your
frontal cortex which is vital to
judgment shuts down isn't that insane
your brain literally deactivates the
part of itself that can criticize and
judge because it knows if you can
maintain your critical thinking you
probably won't put up with as much
and then you won't reproduce to
ensure the survival of your species so
what do we do what do we do when our
brains literally shut down our ability
to think clearly it's very simple but
very hard sit back and observe their
patterns people show you who they are
all the time listen to them they're
always giving you information so my cat
is a Capricorn son a cancer moon and a
Pisces ascendant so like obviously
Wow mm-hmm what's your point what's your
site I'm a Capricorn oh you're a
Capricorn - oh you're just like my kitty
and even if it's someone you're not
romantically attracted to even if you're
just wondering whether or not you should
stay friends with someone or go into
business with a colleague wait and see
what their patterns are don't judge them
on what they say I know I'm a ghost but
I will always be transparent with you
don't judge them on their actions
[Music]
trust their patterns to tell you exactly
who they are the best predictor of
future behavior is past behavior so keep
your hopes and expectations low go slow
and take note of the values in the
person that you're watching and do those
values line up with what you want and a
potential friend partner or colleague
everyone tend to leave all in before I
even really know a person and let me
tell you it has not served me it's
caused me a lot of heartbreak pain
frustration and disappointment I'm Anna
Akana stay right here for an animated
Squarespace add by Bethany Ratliff and
if you're interested in seeing how she
actually creates the graphics on these
videos be sure to check out her twitch
stream where she shows you the process
thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video Squarespace has beautiful
award-winning templates and an
all-in-one platform so there's no
upgrades patches installs or haunts ever
if you need a domain name or an exorcism
they provide a simple and unique set of
experience Squarespace is great for
building any kind of web site whether
you're a ghost a ghoul or a goblin go to
Squarespace comm slash Ana to start your
free trial today and use the offer code
ana for 10% off at checkout